no total teremos mais um vídeo e hoje
você deve produzir um som planejado como
este que é tão super que nem casa tela
aqui você tem que fazer baixar o
template e vocês vão encontrar na minha
página do facebook o linkedin está a
descrição desse vídeo e depois é só
imprimir a imagem é muito importante
definir a escala do vosso tempo e este
mestrado empréstimos calvi 220 horas eu
acho que você viu o desvio era muito
mais querido porque já é grande prêmio
foi um típico churrasco grande poder
treinar você imprimir na escala 180
sendo isso senta e espera usar o
material para do baluquistão bola você
tem que enfrentar escolhas todas foram a
formar o mesmo tempo vocês viram na
página do facebook para nos ajudar no
processo vocês podem perguntar pela
quilos anne mulcahy do clube uma tesoura
em que dois em cada parte do tempo e por
isso é mais fácil trabalhar no frida
[Música]
o colégio infante parte do tempo em uma
cartolina como esta aqui
agora se você estiver em caixas velhos
podem aproveitá los não podem comprar
uma cartolina começa aqui que é bastante
barato nem consegue usar o botão mas o
instinto rapidamento então eu confesso
que os utilizem essas escolas brancas
porque estão muito mais baratos e vão
durar mais tempo
[Música]
seu corpo é da parte com um cuidado
usando utilizado e vocês forem crianças
peso do uso de linhas utilizando o
aparelho então podem fazer isto de borda
da mesma
agora eu vou juntar tudo com muito
cuidado usando uma pistola de cola
quente como esta aqui dentro do lar uma
parte a outra é muito importante que
você utiliza em fita do papel e faça
como estou fazendo aqui
assim vocês vão falar só quando tiver
certeza que está tudo no sítio certo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o
[Música]
é muito importante que nesta parte do
turismo em mim de cola quente para
edificar o bandido externa para fazer o
cabo machado e utilizei um tubo de pvc e
depois com várias etapas da volta não
quiser essa trabalheira toda podem
cortar um pedaço de madeira
[Música]
[Aplausos]
como pedacinho de jornal a volta do voto
machado utilizando um pincel mistura e
utiliza cola pv-ac oportunidade nos
quiserem podem usar só cola perea
[Música]
quando há como ficar têm manchado preto
dos anos pra e não esqueça de utilizar
uma máscara de quadra
para dar a impressão de um cabo de
madeira eu fiz assim alguns riscos
usando uma pistola de cola quente foi
criado foi total e que só vocês vai uma
cinta adoraram então prateada e
direcionando por cima utilizando uma
esponja velha como estanque
depois tentei o cabo visando testar no
escuro e de seguida o quiser um dourado
e espalhamos assim por cima das partes
que outros a escola quer andar assim um
real na parte do risco a volta do carro
com tem feito velho e fui land
comunidade é muito importante você
explorar em que a cola 700 de dar mais
uma volta ou outra pelo tiro voto
machado vocês devem comprar uma lata e
colocar a volta de outubro
assim a quinta vai ficar produtiva e não
vai estragando o tempo
[Música]